the unity and healing that we've all
been hearing so much about
intensified over the weekend as a
million trump supporters gathered in
washington dc
peacefully to rally in support of the
president and
blm and antifa and generally leftist
radicals
started to attack them they threw
projectiles at the trump supporters
while they were eating dinner
they threw fireworks at them i kid you
not they threw
fireworks at them and all the time joe
biden completely
silent democratic leadership completely
silent
with the exception of these meaningless
platitudes to unity
and healing every time that there is any
incident where
any even sort of vaguely right winger
does anything wrong
republican politicians conservatives
trump is told he has to condemn it he's
got to disavow it for the rest of his
life
and yet when the left organizes attacks
peaceful trump supporters during a
contested election
nothing just words of unity and healing
the dc mayor
did nothing to stop the violence i was
in dc at the time
the dc mayor was worried about a much
greater threat you're going to hear a
lot more about this in the coming days
and weeks
she was worried about the scariest thing
of all
people who don't wear masks i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday is from sango
sango says i never liked my
mother-in-law i spent the last 10
minutes yelling at her because she voted
for joe biden
then i left the cemetery and went home i
think it's
it's good i understand your
mother-in-law must live in pennsylvania
maybe no maybe she lives in michigan i'm
not so sure
a lot of shenanigans i've kind of been
all over the place the last few days
i was in los angeles i said goodbye to
my set there flew to
tennessee dropped off sweet little alisa
then flew out a few hours later to dc
during this naga million march i gave a
speech defending the president at yaf
we'll get into a little bit of what went
on there i got the great privilege of
guest hosting for rush limbaugh had the
chance to speak to rudy giuliani
on the trump strategy moving forward as
this election
continues to be contested and now we're
back here in my new set
in nashville there is a whole lot to go
over there are a lot of
i tell you i feel much more secure now
that i'm in nashville than i did when i
was in dc
with these riotous leftists i feel much
more secure than i did when i was in la
with everything boarded up because the
left was threatening to
to burn down the whole city of trump one
but i still don't always feel secure
online because cyber criminals are
always trying to hide malware for
instance in emails
they've got deceptive emails they can
look like real invoices they can look
like invoice
invites they can look like payment
information with a document attached
i have fallen for this before the
attachments contain text and images that
look legitimate then you click on it
and a pop-up can appear and it prompts
you to click enable content or enable
editing or whatever and when you do this
the attachment will install malware on
your computer well
fortunately now i have lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information being
used in their network they will send you
an alert it's so easy for someone to
steal your info i i didn't believe this
before
and then i fall for one of these email
things and all of a sudden you realize
how scary it can be
obviously no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but
lifelock can help you feel warm and
protected
this holiday season save up to 25
percent off your first year
at lifelock.com knowlescannerwles
that is lifelock.com knowlescanwlis
for 25 off
pretty scary stuff going on in dc
but meanwhile the mayor of dc says that
actually
this is a direct quote there is nothing
scarier than having a conversation with
someone
who doesn't have a mask on don't scare
others hashtag mascot dc
now having just been in dc during this
chaos
i think it's actually much scarier to
have a conversation with someone who
does have a mask on who wears masks
historically speaking
train robbers marauders
rioters burglars people trying to
conceal their identity antifa in blm
that's who wears masks
that's very scary the idea that i get to
speak to somebody
who isn't who is i don't know maybe has
a virus maybe doesn't
a virus that it is statistically almost
impossible for me to die from
and for especially for someone in my age
range basically
is no big deal at all uh i'm not so
afraid of that
i'm not so afraid of that at all we
never heard
this kind of hysteria about
other illnesses some of which were much
more life-threatening than coronavirus
and now the coronavirus thing is coming
back now i you know how much i hate to
say i told you so
people said that after the election if
joe biden won
coronavirus would be cured and that
would be it and it would go away
and i thought okay there's something to
that because they're going to want to
give biden the credit for this and start
to be able to reopen the economy a
little bit
so to that degree that's true however
i did caution people about a month or
two months ago i said
i don't think it's all going to go away
actually i think they're going to double
down on some of the measures
because it's just too much power
you know i gave a speech in at yaf about
how i don't wear the mask unless i am
under absolute duress unless
the deli that where i need to get my
hoagie for lunch insists that i wear a
mask
i'm not going to wear the mask
voluntarily i have ignored all of these
rules from the very beginning of this
pandemic and epidemic throughout the
country
i have traveled all over the place all
over the country i've seen friends i've
seen family i have shared
hugs i've shared cigars i've shared
drinks i
have i once i went on vacation with my
friends and
we this was in september august we ate
fondue for dinner
we don't even really like fondue we just
ate the fondue to stick it in the eye of
these experts
who are telling us we can't live our
lives okay i have ignored
the coronavirus guidelines as as best
as possible in this environment i'm fine
still living
still dude still good it never felt
better and by the way do you know who
else has ignored all of these
these guidelines the liberal elites
themselves and we'll get to that
in a second because a few of them are
getting caught regardless
we are being told that we are going to
double down triple down on the
the coronavirus lockdowns on this i
believe it's the 244th day of 15 days to
slow the spread
joe biden's potential chief of staff if
joe biden
ascends to the presidency this guy ron
claim
is promising a nationwide mass mandate
the very first business day of his
transition on monday
this week the president-elect met with
his covet task force and made a public
statement afterwards
where he called on all americans to mask
up he urged governors to impose masking
mandates now and
reiterated the fact that when he becomes
president he will impose one on a
nationwide basis and so
look he's not the president now there's
not that much that joe biden can do
right now to change things other than
to reiterate kind of the message you
heard from dr osterholm which is that
all americans
and our state and local governments need
to step up right now
if the president the administration is
not going to lead that's where the
leadership has to come from that will
change
on january 20th but right now we have a
crisis it's getting worse you know
we had never had a day with a hundred
thousand cases in a single day until
last week
by next week we may see two hundred
thousand
in a single day so this is getting much
worse chuck did you notice the slate of
hand there by the way initially during
the early days of the virus
what we heard about was the number of
deaths and hospitalizations why because
we were told
we needed to 15 days to slow the spread
we needed to flatten the curve right and
flattening the curve
doesn't reduce the number of people who
are going to get it not by one single
person
doesn't reduce the number of deaths from
the virus not by one single person
it just keeps that number below hospital
capacity so people don't die
needlessly if you go over hospital
capacity okay we did that we succeeded
at that
never came even close to capacity in new
york never came close to
capacity in california nowhere else
either but then they shifted the measure
and it was seamless you didn't even
notice they shifted it from deaths and
hospitalizations
to cases well okay if if the survival
rate is somewhere around 99
or or higher then
the cases isn't the most important
measure the measure
ought to be deaths uh
the specifics about deaths and what
hospitalization looks like too
the one true thing that ron klein said
there is that joe biden's not the
president
let me give him credit for that the rest
of what he said though
was absolutely hysterical though it does
prove the point that a lot of
conservatives were worrying about namely
these leftist power grabbers are going
to continue to use this
crisis much of which has been contrived
to
take more power for themselves and
they're not going to give it up
anytime soon now you might be confused
because we've been told
that we're going to get a vaccine
remember just two days after the
presidential election
magically pfizer says we're gonna have a
vaccine for the weeks before the
election when president trump said we're
going to get a vaccine very very soon
the media called him a liar they said he
he was an idiot he had no idea what he
was talking about then two days after
wow what convenient timing
pfizer says they've got a vaccine that's
going to be 90 effective
we then have a another potential vaccine
another potential treatment
95 effective wow oh my gosh that's great
so that means we don't need to wear the
stupid masks anymore right
that filthy cloth that you put on your
face to convince yourself that you're
going to
eradicate germs right now we don't need
that right right wrong dr fauci who
in the beginning of the pandemic told us
do not wear the masks under no
circumstances should you wear the masks
now he's telling us we all have to wear
the masks even after
we get the vaccine here he is speaking
with jake tapper
so just as a public health measure you
think it would be a good idea
if your team would be able to work
with the biden harris transition team
right now just in terms of what's best
for the public health of the american
people
of course jake that's obvious of course
it would be better if we could start
working with them
hold on right there hold on right there
this is what the left always does do you
notice jake tapper with his very earnest
very concerned face
very concerned voice talking to the very
concerned selfless dr
fauci a man who has given his life
dedicated his whole life
just to help us if only we would
appreciate him but we're
so caught up in our petty political
squabbles
we won't just hand over all of our
rights and traditions to dr fauci who
knows better for us than we do for
ourselves
jake tapper says listen dr fatchi
as a purely scientific matter
don't you think we should move into the
presidential transition
dr fauci i'm not i'm not talking about
political matters here
i know people talk about a contested
election
and legal challenges because of
irregularities and outright fraud at
polling places i know they're talking
about that following the
constitutional system but as a
scientific matter
just you know for public health
shouldn't we forget about all that and
kick trump out as fast as possible
not follow the legal process and pretend
that joe biden is already the
president-elect
and dr fauci putting on his exact same
liberal concerned
tone of voice who says yes of course
jake thank you you see
you see what i'm trying to do yes we
need to say that joe biden is the
president even though no state has
certified him
even though the electors haven't voted
even though he's not
the president elect this is what they
always do
this goes back to woodrow wilson this
goes back to the earliest days of the
progressive movement
when they said the constitution's
outdated that's for an old world order
based on an old scientific understanding
that isaac newton gave us they always
tied it to science
they said because we have a new
scientific understanding of the world
brought to us by charles darwin
we know that there are no fixed laws
there are no eternal principles there's
no human nature
we just got to move with how however
organic movement
i decide is important and energetic for
the government
and that's what they're saying here the
the left this is goes back to marx and
hagel
the left pretends that they know the
science
of history so this is why i half
jokingly said
many months ago that we need to
eliminate the word science from
political discourse
and i much less jokingly said that we
should ignore statistics
because the social sciences political
science which is a relatively new field
and and even the modern conception of
science itself
is a product of a progressive
political understanding of the world
whereby
if you declare your political points of
view as science
then they're incontrovertible you can't
debate it you can't dispute it
you're good that's it and any anyone who
disagrees with you
is illegitimate that is how the left has
conducted politics now for well over a
century
that's exactly what you're seeing tapper
and dr fauci doing
here you've got the scientific
understanding so what about the masks dr
fauci
tell us about why we need the masks once
the process is complete
does that mean they can take off their
masks they don't have to social distance
they can just go about their lives as
before
you know i would recommend that that's
not the case i would recommend you have
an
added area of protection obviously
with a 90 plus percent effective vaccine
you could feel much more confident
but i would recommend to people to not
abandon
all public health measures just because
you've been vaccinated because
even though for the general population
it might be 90 to 95 percent effective
you don't necessarily know for you how
effective it is
so when i get vaccinated which i hope to
when when it becomes my turn to get
vaccinated
i'm not going to abandon completely
public health measures
i could feel more relaxed and
essentially not having the stringency of
it
that we have right now but i think
abandoning it completely would not be a
good idea
because five to ten percent of the
people that get immunized it will not be
effective for
so they might actually get the virus if
they just completely let down their
guard
okay that's interesting okay well that's
interesting i'm glad we had this really
open
and important discussion not just a
pre-scripted political hack fest
no that that is exactly what just
happened by the way dr fauci doesn't
believe
any of this dr fauci has been
photographed countless times
ignoring his own mask rules obviously
early on he said don't wear the masks at
all it's ridiculous
to wear the masks then he changed his
mind so i don't know where the
you know the eternal trustworthiness of
science factors in there because he
contradicted himself entirely
he contradicted himself on the vaccine
he said about three or four months ago
he said
we will not get a vaccine that's 100 or
90
or 80 even he said probably about 70
effectiveness we're going to get
well now we got one apparently that's 90
effective or 95
effective so thatchy was wrong about
that too
and yet now it's it's amazing how much
these
scientific leftists fail upwards they
get every single thing
wrong and yet they they rely upon their
authority as the scientific
enlightened liberals to to force us to
follow them
and obviously they're going to get it
wrong again they're going to continue to
get it wrong
dr fauci made a big ostentatious show
of wearing a mask when he dribbled that
baseball at the opening day for the
nationals
remember and he had the mask on even
though he was in the middle of a
baseball
stadium that was completely empty he put
the mask on just to teach you
and then he goes back to his seat he's
sitting next to his his friends
and he's got the mask off for no reason
he wasn't making a phone call he wasn't
eating a potato chip he just had the
mask off
because he thought the cameras weren't
on him then there have been a number of
other photographs of this too and this
is a theme that we're seeing come up
again and again
it's not just a gotcha moment where
fauci let his guard down once or twice
it it seems consistent every time these
liberal elites
think that the cameras are turned off
they take off the masks they ignore
these rules that they want to force onto
the rest of us
and it is in that world that we are
being told
we have to trust them we have to trust
them on everything including the
election
these two stories actually relate pretty
closely the people the liberal elites
who have
lied to us who have first of all either
gotten everything wrong by mistake
during the lockdowns and
and uh other issues over the last four
years
or more likely have lied to us about a
lot of issues for instance
the obama administration spying on the
trump campaign impeachment russia
collusion ukraine collusion you name it
non-traversing after non-traversing
these guys who have no credibility
whatsoever
are now telling us believe us on the
election don't let the legal process
play out i don't think so trump's not
conceding
nor should he he should not concede at
all
okay this uh politics is much more an
art than a science okay even though the
left wants to pretend that it's a
science
it's much more an art conservatives have
a much more artistic sensibility if you
ask me
and that's why if you want the perfect
gift to give your family i would
recommend
paintyourlife.com you know how much i
love paint your life you can get a
professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at an incredibly
affordable price i i can't tell you how
how inexpensive this is especially for
the the quality that you get
i've now done this twice with paint your
life i was very skeptical the first time
and i i got a picture done for my
stepbrother it was for his wedding and
it was in grand central it was actually
a very complex picture with him and his
wife
and it was very large too and i figured
okay i'm gonna have it tried out on him
because then if it's no good he can just
have it at his place
and it was amazing then i thought okay
well you know look i'm i'm a guy who
they sponsor my show maybe they just
gave me the best artist so i tried a
different artist i had them do a
portrait of my mother
even more beautiful than the last one
it's these guys are just amazing you
send any picture in
you can even combine photos into one
painting and then these world-class
artists will work with you every single
step of the way
until your picture is absolutely perfect
the price cannot be beat i did oil you
can do other
you can do other types of painting as
well at paintyourlife.com there is no
risk whatsoever
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded guaranteed right
now is a limited time offer get 20
off additionally of your painting that
is 20 off and free shipping to get this
offer text
michael to 64 000 to mich ael to 64 000
michael text michael to 64 thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most
president trump is not conceding nor
should he
however yesterday on twitter
trump conceded trending that's very
strange why would
trump conceded trend if trump did not
concede
president trump has tweeted out just
just this morning he tweeted out
something to the effect of i will win we
won the election
a couple days ago he tweets out rigged
election we will win all caps
another tweet i concede nothing but then
there was a third tweet
and people are misunderstanding this
because they don't know how to speak
trump broadly they don't know how to
speak new yorker but they they
specifically don't have to speak trump
he tweeted out quote
he won because the election was rigged
no vote watchers or observers allowed
vote tabulated by radical left privately
owned company dominion
with a bad reputation and bum equipment
they couldn't even qualify for texas
which i won by a lot
the fake and silent media and more
so they're saying because he said
because trump said he won
referring to biden then he is conceding
the election
now you can say trump doesn't use
proper diction he his grammar is
eccentric you can say all those things
but no one can honestly read
what trump said as him conceding
and my evidence for this is he used the
same
sort of linguistic structure when he was
talking about john mccain you remember
trump got in a lot of trouble because he
said john mccain's not a war hero
are we famous they said john again is
not a war hero biden continues to attack
him for saying john mccain's not a war
hero
the way he said it though was exactly
the way that he said
joe biden didn't win the election joe
biden did win the election
take a listen to the infamous mccain
comment he hit me
he's not a war hero he's a warrior five
and a half years
he's a war hero because he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you
do you hear that notorious comment how
dare trump say that okay you can you can
dislike the comment all you like and you
can dislike what he's saying about joe
biden right now
but you have to admit when joe when when
trump says
he won because the election was rigged
what he is saying is
people believe that joe biden won
because the election is rigged
even though he didn't really win just as
he said
john mccain's not a war hero he's a war
hero because he was shot down
he's not he's not contradicting himself
he's not saying john mccain's not a war
hero oh actually he is a war hero
he's saying john mccain's not a war hero
people believe he is a war hero because
he's shot down
but nevertheless my assertion is true
he's not a he is not a war hero same
thing here
joe biden did not win the election
people think he won because you know all
this voter fraud or whatever
but he didn't really win that's what
he's saying you can disagree with that
all you want
and we'll find out there's gonna be a
legal process that plays out to see who
ends up being ultimately named president
we may never know who got the most votes
people might have a hunch who got the
most votes but we may never know for
sure
stuffing the ballot box is notoriously
difficult to figure out
it took the the lbj investigators
decades after he
left office to figure that out and it
does happen all the time as we saw with
lbj
and fdr i spoke about that on the show a
little bit last week
in terms of what that legal strategy
looks like for trump i
did have the privilege of speaking to
rudy giuliani on friday when i was
filling in for rush
and rudy giuliani is obviously greatest
mayor in the history of new york and
he's also one of trump's lead attorneys
and he's really pursuing this election
fraud question it is a major uphill
battle
so what mayor giuliani told me is there
are
hundreds of thousands of ballots
something like 600 000 ballots in
pennsylvania
that were illegally counted that's not
to say they were illegally cast
maybe they were maybe they weren't but
they were illegally counted
because there were not poll watchers
there every campaign is permitted to
have poll watchers
to make sure shenanigans don't go on
this is especially important for mail-in
ballots which are much more open to
fraud
so because those 600 000 ballots were
not counted legally
they should not be counted in the final
tally that's mayor giuliani's argument
i don't know that that's going to hold
up in court what do i know the trump
campaign has won some victories in the
pennsylvania courts
however it's very it's difficult to
throw out
six ballots much harder to throw at 60
or 600 to 6000 to threat
600 000 ballots to me seems unlikely
unless the trump campaign can come with
hard irrefutable proof
of systemic fraud there may have been
systemic fraud and it's just impossible
to prove
we don't know but it's going to be
incumbent on the trump legal campaign to
to prove that there are other
irregularities you've heard about the
dominion
software there are allegations from
whistleblowers at dominion by the way
that dominion uh was very easy to misuse
there were people actually saying that
even before the election easy to hack
obviously the left has been telling us
it's easy to hack elections for years
and years now
because of they've never accepted the
results of 2016.
so obviously those questions are all all
wide open
but can you prove it can you prove it
that's the question that's going to be
up
even even if they can't there are going
to be a lot of conservatives who
are skeptical of this election and i i
know there are some people who want to
say come on we need to show
we need to only rely on the evidence we
need evidence right now
i don't think that's fair i don't think
that's fair i think the skepticism that
conservatives have
for these liberal elites is utterly
justified
i think we would be foolish not to look
at them with this skepticism
they have lied to us time and time and
time and time again
they've been wrong time and time and
time and time and time again
and i think absolutely it's they it is
the people who run the liberal
institutions
that have squandered their credibility
it's not conservatives who are
conspiracy mongering because we don't
take them
at face value there are a lot of things
up in the air right now
and when things are up in the air and
chaotic it's very important to have
precious metals
i've always felt that way at least and
the one one issue with precious metals
is when you try to buy gold let's say
you want to buy a bar of gold
it's very very expensive and a lot of
people don't usually have the requisite
cash lying around on the table that's
why
acre gold has come out with an
incredible new product which is
you can even though the price of gold
has been skyrocketing lately
you can buy gold through acre and
acre will let you subscribe to gold bars
for as little as 30
a month so how does that work you know
gold bars cost more than 30
how are you going to do it you pay each
month and once your gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house acre lets you invest in physical
gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
it's very difficult for
most of us to do acre keeps you updated
on your gold stash every month ships
once you reach the price threshold with
acre taking physical delivery of your
gold
means it is safe and sound and in your
hands
acre just recently introduced a new
hundred dollar per month subscription
for their five
gram gold bar i think it's great i've
always enjoyed precious metals
uh visit getacregal.com knoll start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to this url because acre is
giving away a gold bar that's pretty
good
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre
again that is getacre gold.com olsen
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show
i'll give you an example of why we can't
trust any of these
liberal elites so
you remember president trump a number of
months ago pulled troops out of syria
he pulls troops out of syria we were
told this was going to be the end of the
world
it was maybe it was a year ago at this
point we were told this is terrible
you know everyone's going to die it's
going to start world war 3 because trump
is
reducing the number of troops in the
middle east okay well somehow it's going
to start world war iii
and then it was all fine right and
trump's foreign policy really has been
much
much more successful than any of his
predecessors
in my lifetime with the exception of
ronald reagan and maybe george h.w bush
but certainly more successful than
clinton bush ii and obama
even though we were told the sky was
going to fall well now we're finding out
that the deep state they've followed
trump's orders when they have to but
they've also been undermining trump
there was a deep stater named jim
jeffrey career diplomat he's now the
outgoing syria envoy
he just told defense one magazine he
said
we were always playing shell games to
not make clear to our leadership how
many troops we had
in syria the actual number of troops
in northeast syria is quote a lot more
than the roughly 200 troops that that
president trump initially agreed to have
there in 2019.
a washington post reporter specifically
the reporter on syrian affairs
read this interview and laughed about it
said oh it's so funny
we've got these career diplomats these
deep staters
undermining the duly elected president
ha ha isn't that so funny
when a deep stater undermines the
president he is undermining
the people which means he's undermining
the constitutional order
nobody elected jim jeffrey okay jim
jeffrey was hired by the bureaucracy
to be a career a careerist in the
government
people did elect trump and trump did
appoint various people
and jim jeffrey lied to all of those
people and conducted his own foreign
policy
outside of the constitutional order
that's what we're talking about when we
say the deep state or the administrative
state
that is the permanent government that's
the government that will govern us even
when
president trump tries to change a little
bit around the edges
sometimes he won't be successful and
there are a lot of people right now
who believe that the permanent
government the established institutions
are trying to pull a fast one in various
ways
the media most most notably the people
who
actually make up our regime our
political system our order
which increasingly has very little to do
with the constitution
so forgive us our skepticism when we
don't believe it there's something very
strange
going on here something extremely bogus
going on in our political system those
aren't my words those are elon musk's
words
who thinks that there's something
extremely bogus going on
with the way we're talking about
coronavirus we'll get to that in one
second
but first you know that you can't trust
these guys in the legacy media the
establishment media
you know it time to cut the cord time to
describe to subscribe to new media
replacement media like the daily wire
we got a lot of great content coming to
the daily wire obviously we're here in
nashville
we are we we have fled
governor nussolini in california which
was trying to kill our business
basically we are
building up our own place in a in
an area where we can breathe a little
freer we've got a lot new people coming
over we've got
candace owens our friend candace is
going to be coming over to daily wire
we're going to be launching a new show
with her we're going to be launching new
cultural products
we got a whole lot of new stuff going on
the set
is just the first part we are building
out things all over the place
come be a part of it with us join
especially at the all access tier that
is the elite
level of membership and we get to hang
out with you guys and i get to steal
ideas from you if you join
all access head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now to replace that
awful desiccated establishment media
that lies to you all the time
we'll be right back with a lot more
i have told you from the very beginning
that i think that the public policies
surrounding coronavirus are completely
bogus and stupid and i've been ignoring
basically all of them as much as i
possibly can and i encourage all of you
to do that as well
well now it seems like i'm being joined
by elon musk
in my skepticism of some of these
policies elon musk
just tweeted out quote something
extremely
bogus is going on was tested for covid
four times today
two tests came back negative two came
back positive
same machine same test same nurse
rapid antigen test from bd okay
so that is weird that's pretty weird
right you get the exact same test in the
exact same place from the exact same
person and two of them come back
positive
two of them come back negative was it a
false positive it would seem to be
could i guess it could have been a false
negative but i think in the case of elon
musk it'd be false positives
so maybe we can't rely on that so much
maybe we can't rely on dr fauci who's
been wrong and changed his mind every
single step of the way
maybe we can't rely on these genius
andrew cuomo probably the greatest
example of this we're told he's the
most important governor on coronavirus
he wrote a book about leading through
coronavirus
andrew cuomo's policies killed thousands
of elderly new yorkers he handled the
virus worse
than any other politician in the entire
country
and we're told to follow him
why why what's the uh show me the
evidence
there there i guess there's some
evidence of some effectiveness of the
masks that we've got
we've quoted on this show
epidemiologists from colombia have
quoted this to
npr we've quoted cdc studies that show
that the masks are not particularly
effective
the one columbia epidemiologist said
that they're not effect maybe they would
be effective in a perfect world but
they're not effective in the way
that people use them because they touch
their face they wear them incorrectly
okay makes sense if you keep some filthy
cloth mask in your pocket for three
weeks at a time it's probably not going
to be all that sanitary right
well we now have more evidence that not
even the liberal elites pushing these
policies believe in them
as i have been suggesting from the very
beginning
i think these liberal elites don't think
covet is a serious issue at all i think
they're playing the american people for
suckers
and the liberal elites themselves are
not worried in the slightest nancy
pelosi
well she tells us that we can't go to
funerals for our grandfathers while she
tells us
we can't go to church while she tells us
it's dangerous to go vote you got to
vote by mail
she's also hosting a big dinner party
big fancy dinner party
for all the incoming new members of
congress
well that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense she actually
her defense of this was don't worry
it'll be safe it's very spaced out
that's preposterous what because the
tables are going to be five or six feet
apart
the covet isn't going to spread if
you're having a giant dinner party
but then she actually posted a picture
of it doesn't look very spread out at
all
the covid is not going to spread when
you're when you're seated
eight inches away from this person
sitting next to you but five feet away
from the person at the table next to you
but it is going to spread if you
protest for your civil liberties it is
going to spread if you go to church it
is going to spread if you
see your dying relatives
i don't believe that for a second not
just pelosi gavin newsom mussolini
just got caught even the sacramento b
which is a
very liberal newspaper is crushing
newsome for this
the sac b is pointing out the gavin
newsom had a very fancy birthday party
at a very very fancy restaurant called
french laundry
i think the average dinner is like 350
bucks per person
or higher and he had a very fancy
birthday party with very fancy lobbyists
all sitting privately in this room
and then he got caught he thought the
cameras were off just like all these
guys when they think the cameras are off
ignore all the same
stupid rules that they're trying to
force on you and the gullible people
believe
he got caught and then he sort of
apologized whoopsie daisy yup
now that's that's too bad okay i'll do
better yeah
no i mean it was okay though so we all
knew these people even though
even though the people at this dinner
were of very different households not
just new cellaini
chicago mayor lori lightfoot attended a
massive joe biden victory rally
when the media baselessly declared him
the president-elect
lori lightfoot shows up there with
thousands of people
to cheer on joe biden all very close
does she think the virus isn't going to
spread there
well she defends herself she says hey at
least we were wearing masks
what do you say to those who are
criticizing you
where less than a week ago you went out
and stood before
a massive crowd who was celebrating um
joe biden's victory and now you're
saying your city has to shut down how do
you have one and not the other
well look i i think that we've been
saying all along everybody has to take
care
everybody has to take precaution i will
tell you in that big crowd
a week ago we had everybody was wearing
masks look at
you can see the shot here uh mass
compliance in our city
is actually up very very high the
funniest part of that whole clip i mean
it's a ridiculous defense but the
funniest part of that whole clip is she
says look
look everybody here was wearing a mask
and a lot of people were wearing masks
in the picture i don't think the masks
were doing very much when all these
people are touching each other
you know by the thousands but the best
part of the clip is lori lightfoot
wasn't wearing a mask
she was there without a mask on because
look oh it's totally fine
everybody there was wearing a mask it's
cool
ma'am you are you are lying not just
through your teeth certainly not through
your mask
you're lying about your own actions you
are telling us to believe your words
rather than our lying eyes
she cued up the clip that showed her not
wearing a mask that is how brazen
these people are lori lightfoot doesn't
believe that coronavirus is going to
kill her
she's not afraid of it at all if you
really were afraid of coronavirus you
would never go out into that crowd
if you really were afraid of coronavirus
you would never go to french laundry for
your fancy dinner with lots of your
fancy rich friends
if you really were terrified of
coronavirus you would never hold this
big fancy party for the incoming members
of congress
these people aren't afraid of all at all
at all of this
and as president trump said you should
not live your life in fear of the virus
either
i know i feel bad i mean some of my
friends and relatives
are gullible enough to believe that this
is really
worth shutting down the world over this
is the existential threat you've got to
stay in your homes they believe these
liars these scoundrels who don't believe
it themselves
i've been ignoring this basically the
whole time and so my life is basically
fine especially now that i'm in
tennessee which is much more sane
than california but a lot of people have
had their lives ruined by this
their livelihood's ruined they've lost
their businesses a lot of people have
not been able to see their beloved
relatives as they were dying
usually not of coronavirus right just
people die you know and you you can't
spend time with your relatives as
they're dying
a lot of people have missed very
important moments in their life high
school graduation
weddings have been postponed people have
written into me they said michael
you know my great-aunt thelma doesn't
want to come because she's afraid of
coronavirus should i postpone my wedding
i said don't postpone your wedding do
your what get married
live your life think about the lives
ruined by this children traumatized by
this
cultural insanity all because these
ghouls these ghouls like nancy pelosi
and gavin newsom and lori lightfoot are
lying
to your face about their fear
of the virus and all for what all
to win some elections all to affect
their policy
there is no question regardless of of
your
fear or or lack of fear from the
medical effects of this virus there is
no question it's being exploited for
political purposes
justin trudeau told us that the the
pretty boy
mayor or prime minister i guess of
canada
i can see you know i consider canada to
be america's hat so i i consider the
canadian prime minister to be sort of
like a mayor of a quasi-american city
justin trudeau described this use the
phrase
reset for how politicians can exploit
the virus pandemic building back better
means getting support to the most
vulnerable while maintaining our
momentum on reaching the 2030 agenda for
sustainable development
and the sdgs canada is here to listen
and to help this pandemic has provided
an opportunity
for a reset this is our chance to
accelerate our pre-pandemic efforts
to reimagine economic systems that
actually address global challenges like
extreme poverty
inequality and climate change
this has offered a reset
this pandemic has offered a reset
what a ghoul what a sociopath you have
to be
to look at look if their hysteria is
correct that this is
one of the worst deadliest most terrible
diseases scourges that's ever faced
mankind
then to call it an opportunity is is
pretty callous
but even just looking at the real
effects of it you know people have died
many many more people have had their
lives ruined from it
many many many more people have
undergone traumas from it
to call that an opportunity you have to
be a sociopath
which these people are they're
sociopaths
and they all use the same phrase joe
biden uses build back better
build back joe biden says build back
better justin trudeau has built back
better boris johnson in the uk who's i
guess
ostensibly a conservative build back
better
it's like a blob just a globalist blob
all all around us
very very spooky and i don't think this
is an opportunity i think this is
this is a a political op i think it's an
operation of
politicos to exploit
a pandemic they've got very radical
plans
you know if you had said
just a few years ago that uh
that democrats would call 73 million
americans
nazis i wouldn't have believed you i
wouldn't have believed any of that
but that's what they're doing you know
david frum who's
used to be kind of a conservative now i
guess he's just a total liberal
david frum came out and and he posted a
picture of
a nazi parade and he said this is what
we were promised for the maga parade in
dc but then you know that isn't what we
got
and i realized these guys are not just
calling trump hitler anymore they're
calling
they're calling all the trump supporters
nazis that's half of the country
christian amanpour who drew clavin calls
christian christian
i'm a poor journalist said on cnn she
made this explicit comparison
compared trump supporters to nazis
and evoked crystal knocked this week
82 years ago kristallnacht happened it
was the nazis warning shot across the
bow of our human civilization
that led to genocide against a whole
identity
and in that tower of burning books it
led to an attack on fact
knowledge history and truth after four
years of a modern day assault on those
same values by donald trump
the biden harris team pledges a return
to norms
including the truth and every day joe
biden makes presidential announcements
about good governance
and the health and security of the
american people while the great brooding
figure of his defeated opponent
rages conducting purges of deceived
enemies
and preventing a transition so
everything in there obviously is false
what's so funny is as christian amanpour
is talking about how the
conservatives are burning books target
was taking my friend
abigail schreier's book off the shelves
because she suggested maybe we shouldn't
trans the kids
her book is called irreversible damage
it's a terrific book
target removed it because she said they
said it was transphobic it's now
abigail schreier by the way believes
that if you're an adult you should be
able to
be a man and identify as a woman and go
through the medical
cosmetic procedures to look more like a
woman and identify as a woman she's
totally on board with that she just
thinks she shouldn't trans the kids
take them off the shelves we made a big
deal about it on
on friday and finally target actually
did acquiesce because
when conservatives have courage when
they grow a spine turns out we can
actually do things
but that's that's what's happening there
how about you're worried about crystal
knocked you're worried about the
broken gla you might have broken glass
you're worried about all these things i
notice
that there are a lot of boards in a lot
of shop windows in major cities in
america
do you know why those are up because
they felt the shop owners felt
that if trump won leftists would smash
up their windows
christian poor exactly reverses it says
it's going to be conservatives who do
that conservatives haven't done that
like ever i don't think they've done it
once
and then you have barack obama coming
out
and putting just the perfectly fine
point on the end of it
he accuses trump of being a tyrant
i think that there has been
this sense over the last several years
that
literally anything goes and is justified
in order to get power and
that's not unique to the united states
there are strong men
and dictators around the world who think
that i can do
anything to stay in power
i can kill people i can throw them in
jail i can
run phony elections i can
suppress journalists um
but that's not who we're supposed to be
but that is who obama is because obama
did all of those things and trump has
done none of those things
obama weaponized the federal government
weaponized the irs to go after his
political opponents
threw dinesh d'souza in jail through a
selective prosecution because dinesh
d'souza wrote a mean book about him and
made a mean movie about him that was
very successful
he spied on the trump campaign used his
executive agencies to spy on the trump
campaign to undermine the 2016 election
so he wouldn't have to give up power for
for the liberal blob
he then weaponized the agencies to then
try to launch this coup d'etat for
another three and a half four years
and now who knows what happened in this
election who knows what shenanigans we
know some shenanigans went on
we just don't know which barack obama
bragged about how he violated the
constitution with executive amnesty
he said executive amnesty would be
unconstitutional then he did it anyway
bragged i got a phone and a pen i can
override our constitutional norms
that is the guy who abused his power
they always do this they always project
they accuse conservatives or do of doing
what they themselves are doing now they
say because president trump won't
concede an election
before the legal process plays out
before the constitutional process plays
out because he won't concede it early
and take them at their word that he's
abusing his power and abusing
their norms give me a break
give me a break president trump concedes
nothing right now we should concede
nothing for the moment
to this liberal blob these liars these
scoundrels these sociopaths
who care about nothing but taking more
and more and more
power we should concede nothing
for now you know there's always you
always hear about tactical retreats and
things like that usually from people
who want to give up too soon now is not
the time for retreat there may be there
may be times to re-examine our strategy
but not now these guys have not only
lost all their credibility they are
abusing their power right now and
they're promising to make it a lot
worse do not concede
now i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. you know the matt wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen
you